Resegmented market--well, you have a hypothesis about who the customers are--
that is you think you understand what your fit is, either in the low cost
or there are specific in each needs and so you might have a better fit for them.
And competitors, there's many if you're wrong but very few if you're right,
and your risk is that you get the market and product redefinition just wrong.
You didn't do enough customer discovery and you say--
"No, no, no. This is how we're going to enter this existing market.
We're going to go after these set of usuals specifically," and oops, you are wrong.
A great example of this is what Southwest did.
Southwest took on the airline industry by bringing up the traditional hub-and-spoke model
and providing just very limited services but for an extremely low price.